with absolutely no delay because I
respect all of you too much to delay any
further let's get right into the wacky
political happenings in Warren Michigan
that took place over the weekend later
we're going to get into Marjorie Taylor
Green's latest claim that Democrats are
out there assassinating Republicans
willy-nilly it's not true we'll get to
it a little bit later but where was this
all happening well it was happening in
Warren Michigan because failed former
president Donald Trump dripping wet just
the sweat dripping off of him more
orange than ever visibly scared about
what is his future in this country in
the context of four or more criminal
investigations against him dripping just
slathered
he rallied in Michigan
supposedly in support of a number of
different Republicans he barely spoke
about them as is often the case the
rallies are all about him one such
Republican is Tudor Dixon that's her
name Tudor Dixon and she is getting
crushed right now by the Democratic
incumbent Governor Gretchen Whitmer
despite Trump attacking Whitmer for the
last three years since covet started
Trump starts his rally in Warren
Michigan he now has a new election
hypothesis he claims that a guy named
John James won his Senate race in 2020.
John James lost his Senate race in 2020.
so it's it's not just Trump's election
that now he is lying about
with no basis in fact whatsoever he goes
I think John James actually won now you
might be like no John James isn't a
senator and you'd be right because he
lost
and somebody that I've known for a long
time he did great I think he happened to
win the last election for the Senate I
happen to think he won it by quite a bit
and now he's way leading he's doing a
fantastic job he's got the John James
lost his election he didn't win had he
won he would be a senator right now
Donald Trump also makes the
extraordinarily disturbing comment that
we will never have a fair election again
in the United States well then why would
anyone vote but I'm afraid we have never
had we and I don't believe I don't
believe we'll ever have a fair election
again wow that's a big statement now
certainly not if Trump has his say I
mean listen were it for Trump had Trump
gotten his way in 2020
the president right now would be the guy
who didn't win anything it would have it
would be the guy who not only lost the
popular vote also lost the electoral
vote he would be president right now so
when they say things like this what we
should hear is them saying if it's up to
us there will never be a fair election
in this country again uh Donald Trump
then still not really knowing much about
dogs listen to what he has to say about
dogs so think of it they're against all
of those things
the way they win is to cheat in
elections they cheat like dogs they
cheat like dogs dogs don't cheat Donald
Trump we know his relationship with our
canine friends is clearly very scrambled
but dogs don't really cheat dogs
actually are very much the opposite okay
Trump then suggests that China infected
uh the U.S with covid
to punish us because of the tariffs that
Trump put on China which of course Trump
still doesn't understand are actually
paid by American companies the American
companies pay the tariffs when they
import Chinese Goods we save many
Industries we took in 100
tariffs and taxes from China they did
not
that's why a lot of people said I wonder
why covet came here I wonder why that's
another it's another conspiracy theory
the reason covet came here I mean okay
fine it started in China
and then it went to Italy and then it
went to London and that okay eventually
it got here it was set by China through
many other countries as punishment for
tariffs which our own companies paid
it's economics guys don't you understand
what's so confusing about that uh Trump
then lies and this is part of like the
lurid Stories part of his rallies Trump
lies that Democrats support abortion
after birth what who has ever said that
no one but radical Democrats believe in
abortion
and really right from the moment of
birth and even after birth you can't let
this happen there's no country in the
world that wants what these crazy people
want they are radical they want to
accept it's all not true babies from the
wombs remember during the debate with
crooked Hillary Clinton I said they want
to rip the baby from the womb even in
the ninth month
Michigan you need to dump this wild eye
extremist Gretchen Whitburn Whitmer is
going to win and of course there are
essential statistically there are almost
no abortions in the ninth month talk to
OB gyns I've done it we've done it on
the show we've talked about it
essentially does not happen if a woman
comes in at you know 38 weeks pregnant
and says I think I want an abortion what
you think OB GYN scope sure have an
abortion uh and then of course the the
post-birth thing is just completely
fabricated Trump then says that they
presumably Democrats I guess want to see
him in prison I think they'd like to see
me in prison can you imagine I think
that like you know why yeah you know why
because they're sick they're sick sick
people
um one of the things that's interesting
is these Republicans love to say they
are for Law and Order all the time they
say it we're for Law and Order we're for
Law and Order
my position as someone on the left is
not I want to see Trump in prison I'm
out for blood it's if there is evidence
that Trump should be charged then charge
him
and then if he is convicted sentence him
appropriately and maybe that'll include
prison time that's Law and Order
okay not what they claim Trump then uh
sort of waxes poetic about authoritarian
Chinese president XI where he talks
about how great it is that he's just
killing drug dealers much of the crime
wave is caused by drug dealers who
during their lives will kill an average
of 500 American citizen think of it
think of it and I tell the story I'll
tell it quickly but when I was dealing
with China
and when I was dealing with Russia and
when I was dealing with all this country
I got to know more well and I asked
president XI they have 1.5 billion
people
and they'd say is he smart I say yes
he's smart then the Press would say he's
saying president she is but he is the
ruler of 1.5 billion he's smart very
smart beyond smart I said president do
you have a drug problem anyway then he
tells the story of how she told him that
they execute the drug dealers and they
have like a hundred percent conviction
rate when I hear about a hundred percent
conviction rate I start wondering is
that really a fair justice system but
Trump is completely enamored by it then
we get to the big finish which now
includes a sort of Q Anon music backdrop
uh this is now a regular part of these
rallies in the history of the world
[Music]
I have not added this music last time
some of my viewers thought I added the
music this they are now doing this at
the rally
[Applause]
[Music]
but now
we are a nation in Decline
we are a failing Nation
we are a nation that has the highest
inflation in 50 years so anyway uh why
is it that the Cults never have good
music I've noticed that there's the
music's always so weird
um we laugh to avoid crying because this
is really really disturbing and it sort
of gets awkward at one point during this
musical portion of the speech when Trump
talks about brutal murders he he loves
using these lurid examples of violence
to whining about flight cancellations
which of course don't affect him since
he flies private and it's all really
awkward thieves are allowed to go into
stores
and openly robbed them beat up the help
and killed people they will kill people
and they kill them at will if necessary
and even if not necessary
and there is no retribution they're
doing necessary and unnecessary killings
well if they're necessary are they
really evil what does that even mean we
are a nation whose once revered airports
are a dirty crowded mess where you sit
and wait for hours and then are notified
that the plane won't leave
and they have no idea
when they will as a nation Trump also is
furious that he has not gotten credit
for some of his recent flights to his
frequent flyer miles when they will be
delivered and when you will be delivered
to your destination it's all right I
can't I can't do any more of it but it's
gone completely cult-like and an
extraordinarily dangerous and unhinged
speech the good news if there's any is
that a bunch of the people Trump is
supporting in Michigan seem to be
heading towards some pretty humiliating
losses one last really funny moment I
believe this was after the speech but
maybe it was before and again the speech
was in Michigan this guy Brian Glenn
who's one of the hosts on right side
broadcasting network this guy Brian has
been interviewing Trump for years all
over the country they go to Every rally
and Trump
talks to him about your Governor
Gretchen Whitmer as if he doesn't even
recognize that this is the same dude who
is not from Michigan and he's been
interviewing Trump dozens of times a
year look at this isn't
use of the people from Michigan and your
Governor's done a very poor job as you
know we've lost a lot of business in
Michigan they've lost a lot of jobs in
Michigan I think tutor's going to do
very well Mr President always a pleasure
so anyway Trump doesn't even seem to
know who he's talking about there scary
stuff but remember it's always scarier
that people follow this stuff and that's
what we're going to talk about next I
often have a very hectic schedule and I
don't always have the time to plan the
exact nutrition of all of my meals but
our sponsor athletic greens just makes
it easy to make sure I'm getting the
nutrients I want I've been using it for
almost a year now and it's great ag1 by
athletic greens is a delicious
plant-based blend of 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics from
whole food sources if I have just one
small scoop of ag1 a day I know I'm
getting the nutrition and nutrients that
I want that that support all of the
things that are important to me the only
alternative would be to take 20
different vitamin pills and things every
day I'm not doing that I don't want to
do that ag1 is super tasty you can put
it in a smoothie I drink it straight
achieving good nutrition and feeling
your best does not have to be
complicated you can make AG one part of
your daily routine the way I have done
when you go to athleticgreens.com Pacman
you will get a one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs the
link is down below